hello everyone and welcome to yet
another interesting game from round
eight of the 2013 candidates tournament
it's steam our job of versus Boris
Gelfand there's already a critical
position on the board here but you know
you haven't seen anything and before we
see this game let's check out a couple
of photos we have from this round here
we have a starting position get on with
his usual start glass of water with a
nice expresso and we still haven't
figured out what Roger Bob is having who
we have two nice close-ups of Boris
Gelfand here I believe it's also before
the first move was made and here also
also another not a nice close-up of
Boris Gelfand now we also have two more
photos but those are from the press
conference so we'll save them for after
the game so you already seen a Kramnik
versus fiddler that brilliant play by
kramnik that one another important point
in round 8 and you've seen vastly one
should lose yet another game on time
versus Alexander Greece trip so here we
have it a job of opens the game with
Knight to f3 we have C 5 C 4 so the
English opening is on the board Knight
to c6 b 4c captures on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 we have e 6 g3 Queen to b6 knife
to b3 getting the knight out of the way
Knight to e5 and now e for Bishop to b4
Queen to d2 d 6f for attacking the
knight Knight to c6 and Bishop to e3
first Bishop captures on c3 this comes
with check pawn captures and now Queen
to c7 Bishop to g2 and this is the
interesting position of this game as
Griffin says that there will be a link
in the description below you can check
it out after every video of the 2013
candidates tournament you can check out
some more photos in the description BB
link and also you can check out an
article by Peter Dodgers about every
round of the candidates and there you
will also have videos about from the
press conferences after this game so
this is the calendar already the
critical moment in the game because
Garen says that he had this position
numerous times on the boards throughout
80s and 90s and you were always either
Castle here maybe he would go be six
prepare to do light square bishop but
here he played a five and if I've was
considered to be a novelty here which
caused a job of to spend quite a lot of
time but the thing is this isn't really
a novelty this move was already played
by a very strong player Viktor Korchnoi
played this move in 1988 against
Fernandez and I will put a link to that
game in the description below as well if
you want to check it out so it's I don't
know why they considered this if I move
a novelty maybe because this is the
first time it was used on such a high
level but I don't know if course no use
that then that should definitely count
but either way okay II five and now
comes c5 and this is also one of the
positions that gelfand talks about in in
the press conference the thing is here
the engine suggests C captures on the D
captures on c5 and after Bishop captures
the engine suggests capturing on
therefore but as no player really
understands why the engine is suggesting
this
that's why no one plays it and Jeff and
says that this doesn't really do
anything for black that this only plays
into White's hands so after the c5 move
Gelfand decides to go b6 and this move
was also played in in the game Fernandez
verses cautionary but then it had a
different continuation so b6 we have
seek after some d6 Queen captures on d6
and now castles get on castles as well
and now comes f5 r.java decides to close
the position here
rook to d8 we have rook after d1 and
Queen to a3 rook capture some d8 Knight
captures on the 8th and now Bishop to g5
rush up to a6 attacking the Queen a
Queen to d2 and now Queen back to e7
that seems like a weird square to put
the Queen you know right in front of
this Bishop on g5 but as Gaston will
show at this this makes sense
rook to d1 now comes Knight to b7 brush
up to f3 r up to d8 eater
forcing the Queen to move a queen to see
one and now rook captures Queen cap
Bishop captures and now comes Knight to
d6 Delfin does have a better pawn
structure here you can see the the
isolated upon the isolated C pawn so
those are all potential future targets
and gelfand it doesn't mind trading
pieces Bishop captures on f6 as d4 pawn
was attacked twice so he decides to take
care of it this way G captures on f6 and
Queen to e3 now gay fund also has a
double F phone but as you'll see in the
game this is a lot less important than
the week C and the week a pawn queen to
c7 and now our job of has to make a very
important decision what what does he do
next he does have a lot of problems here
the c3 pawn is weak as we've said da to
pawn also very weak at the bishop on d1
not very active but also nothing is
defending the bishop on d1 so this is
something you would definitely want to
take care of first
the thing is if you do something like
Bishop to e2
I'll just let's say you want to exchange
pieces and then you know exchange you're
a weak Bishop for 4 Gelfand strong
bishop then comes the Bishop captures
Queen captures and now Queen captures in
c3 so you lose a pawn and here it would
just be a slow death for black black for
white black has a nice advantage on the
Queen side and he occasionally which
really push this to victory
another thing after Queen to c7 if you
decide to do something like a bishop to
c2 maybe decide to activate the bishop
this way then the problem is this
instant Queen c4 already black is a
threatening checkmate here and you do
have to react to this after Knight - d -
now you attack the Queen also the Knight
is guarding the F once were but now you
lose the a to pawn and again after some
fiber to d3 check King moves and now
comes push up to b7 there's a nice
pressure on d4 pawn and again there's
this huge advantage on the Queen side
black can just march this a pawn to
victory also would be a very slow death
for white
so after this Queen to c7 what a job of
decided to push a for but a4 as you'll
see also doesn't work
because of Queen to d7 it's it's a very
nice move by Boris Gelfand the queen is
now again threatening to capture the f4
pawn and now as you've seen the Queen
aligned itself or herself with the
undefended Bishop on d1 so it's very
hard to decide what to do here in the
game or a job of pushed a5 with the idea
that he wants to mess up black's pawn
structure but now there is there's this
problem of of this bishop and the one
being undefended so I don't want you to
pause the video here and find find the
winning idea here for Gelfand so for
those of you I will give it a couple of
seconds as usual but for those of you
who were able to find it
congratulations you are an excellent
tactician and the photos you just want
to enjoy the show in the game are a job
of found and Knight captures on e4 which
is a winning move but there is an even
fancier move which is Queen to b5 if you
found Queen to b5 then you are the newer
machine going to be five with the
immediate threat of Queen to f1
checkmate once you stop this now comes
Knight to c4 attacking the Queen also
the knight Knight captures Queen
captures again you're threatening Queen
to f1 checkmate and after Queen blocks
this now comes the bishop be captures on
a5 and now you're simply gonna push this
pawn to victory and it's all over
whatever white place that's simply
blacks plan and there's really no
stopping this you would a white will
have to give up this light square Bishop
at some point but okay Knight captures
on e4 what what the elephant played was
is also quite quite winning so if you
found that congratulations as well now
what was the idea of course if Queen
captures then Queen captures and d1
that's very annoying as Queen King to f2
Queen to f1 check King moves and now
Queen - it will be checkmate
so of course our job of did not capture
the night instead Bishop to c2 was
played but now comes clean to b5 the
idea that also was working a move ago
the threat is once again Queen to f1
checkmate so Queen to f3 preventing this
but now comes Knight to g5 simply
attacking the Queen
- gee - and now B captures on it if I
was played and it was in this position
that team or the job of resigned the
game what if you resign well it's pretty
much the same position we've had they're
simply pushing the upon to victory this
is unstoppable and Roger doesn't want to
be punished like this so so he resigns
but there wasn't even there wasn't even
fancy or moving the position instead of
this slow death
you have you have the very forcing
Knight to h3 check and now whatever
white place simply loses only moves our
king - Queen captures and King - h1 if
you flicking - h1 then comes brush up to
b7 a very nice move simply attacking the
Queen that's aligned with the king so
you either lose the Queen or Queen
captures and then comes Queen to F 1
this will be checkmate and another very
nice variation after Knight to h3 check
if Queen captures then comes Queen to e2
and there's really no good defense
against Queen to e1 check but also even
if you stop this then Queen to e3 check
will also be very deadly as a bishop to
b7 will finish the job even if you try
if you try to defend then you lose the G
- square for the King then it's over
immediately but any other move loses
who's is quite the same
so after this B captures on a5 Raja will
resign the game and the first victory
for Boris Gelfand in this candidates
tournament in the second half of the
tournament in round 8 and what a nice
victory now it's it's not that that if
I've move just one get on the game it
was a nice idea the idea cautionary had
in 1988 but it cost her job a lot of
time and you know he he didn't have time
later in the game for it for some some
very important decisions so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and we
will not talk about the standings just
yet as will show one more game from this
round as it's a very important game
between the leaders Magnus Carlsen vs.
11 our onion but we do have a couple of
more photos this is a photo of a job of
from the press conference here you can
see is he he is beaten and it's always
it's always hard to lose an important
chess game
let alone one from the from the
candidates tournament so and here is
Boris Gelfand after the game you know
he's surprising that smile but that
winning smile is definitely there so
yeah once again I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Miriam Borka and
Thomas Schmidt for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
the Carlson vs. Ariane game from round 8
of the 2013 candidates tournament thank
you all and I will see you soon